This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Alice.
And I'm Neil. Did you have a good weekend, Alice?
Yes, but it flew by, which means it went quickly.
And here we are again, back at work.
I know what you mean.
Though I must say time really dragged for me,
and that means it went slowly.
I was on a train which broke down.
Oh, dear.
And it felt like it took forever to arrive,
though actually it was only delayed by one hour.
Well, today we are talking about our perception of
or the way we see time.
It's true that when we're busy doing lots of things,
time flies by.
And when we're bored,
we'll have nothing to do. It drags.
And I didn't have anything to do on the train.
Do you think time flows at the same rate for everyone?
Even animals?
My cat doesn't get bored doing nothing all day.
I wonder if time drags for her sometimes.
Good question.
Did you know Neil that, according to a new study,
smaller animals perceive time as if
it is passing in slow motion?
Oh, that sounds weird.
Do you think they hear us like this?
Torqueen slowly.
Don't be silly, Neil.
What I meant was that small animals,
such as insects and small birds,
can observe more detail in a certain period of time.
For example, a second than larger animals.
And how does this help them exactly?
It sounds like the day would really drag
if every second got stretched out like that.
It helps them by giving them time to escape larger predators.
Now, I have a question for you, Neil.
Can you tell me roughly how much more quickly a flies eye
can react than a human eye?
Is it a twice as quickly,
b four times as quickly,
or c 10 times as quickly?
Well, I'll go for c 10 times.
Flies are pretty nippy,
and that's another word for quick.
Yes, well, we'll find out later on
if you've got the answer right or not.
Now, small animals can typically process
more visual information than we can.
But in a dangerous situation,
our brains can work in overdrive
to process information more quickly.
And overdrive means a state of extreme activity.
Let's listen to Raza Rumi,
a writer and broadcaster in Pakistan,
talking about the unusual way his brain worked
when gunmen opened fire on him in his car.
It lasted for a few minutes,
but to me that particular incident feels like it was for hours.
I think my brain was working in a very strange way,
parallel and multiple thoughts
and streams of consciousness were sort of running along.
I have to save my head because
if I get a bullet in my brain, I'm dead.
And at the same time,
was it all worth it?
And that's what a short life it was.
It was lovely.
I was petrified that I'm going to die.
Raza Rumi there.
So he was petrified by the attack,
which means extremely frightened.
As a result, his brain started working in a strange way.
He was thinking and feeling lots of different things at the same time.
That's right.
He remembers thinking practical thoughts like I have to save my head.
But in parallel or at the same time,
he also remembers having philosophical thoughts,
such as what a short life it was.
It was lovely.
Have you ever been in a dangerous situation
where your brain went into overdrive?
Yeah, I was 10 years old
and I fell backwards out of a big tree in our garden.
Oh, no.
Yeah, I have a vivid memory of the sun flashing above me
and the clouds moving across the sky
and the leaves rustling in the trees above me.
My mom was screaming through the kitchen window as she saw me fall.
I experienced so much in the space of just a few seconds.
Just like Raza Rumi describes.
Yes, a vivid memory, by the way, is clear and detailed.
How poor Neil, did you hurt yourself?
Some big bruises, but no broken bones.
Glad to hear it.
Now, it's a strange trick of memory
that in a scary situation,
your brain starts to record everything in great detail.
And the more memory you have of an event,
the longer you believe it took.
This idea explains why children often feel
that time is passing slowly
because their experiences are new
and they are creating lots of new memories.
Whereas boring grown-ups like us
are following routines that don't require new memories
because they're so familiar.
But let's listen to Claudia Hammond,
author of Time Warped,
talking about how we can stretch time
and make our days feel longer in a good way.
If you can spend your weekend filling it
with loads of new different activities,
it will go fast at the time because you're having fun.
But when you look back, say, on Sunday night
and you've got to go to work next day,
it will feel as if your weekend was long
because you filled it with new memories.
We should do that this weekend, Neil.
What do you think?
Definitely.
I'm going to buzz around like a fly
creating loads of new memories.
Now, are you ready for the answer to today's quiz question?
I asked roughly how much more quickly a fly's eye
can react than a human eye?
Is it A, twice as quickly,
B, four times as quickly,
or C, ten times as quickly?
And I said C, ten times as quickly.
The correct answer is B, four times as quickly.
Flys have eyes that send updates to the brain
at much higher frequencies than our eyes
because they can process the information more quickly.
This speed illustrates the impressive capabilities
of even the smallest animal brains.
Well, before we buzz off,
perhaps we should hear the words we learned today.
They are, flew by, dragged,
perception, nippy, overdrive,
petrified, in parallel.
Well, that's the end of today's six-minute English.
Remember to join us again soon.
Bye.
English from the BBC.